hallo leute ich finds wieder kari und
ich war heute in münster mit meinem
neuen skateboard dass man hier sieht
und ich bin total happy die sonne
scheint ist es kalt wir waren gerade in
göttingen haben ein neues video gedreht
was ihrem sonntag seht und wir
beantworten jetzt wieder eure fragen
die erste frage die erste frage herr die
ist die frage ist von swarovski den
hatten jedoch die verantwortung jetzt
nochmal meine die netze ausgeschnitten
habe okay also die geschenke sollen doch
unter einen weihnachtsbaum liegen oder
aber der scheint zu fehlen
weihnachtslieder habe ich auch nicht
gehört was für musik spielt euch da
kaspersky hat die weihnachts episode
gesehen von uns die wir letztes jahr
gemacht haben bei uns zu hause übrigens
hier im haus von meinen eltern in
münster
hier sind wir gerade auf der straße und
du hast dich gefragt warum wir keinen
weihnachtsbaum tragen und keine
weihnachtslieder singen
das liegt daran dass zwei machten immer
anders ist in jeder familie wird
weihnachten anders gefeiert und manche
haben weihnachtsbaum manche haben keinen
weihnachtsbaum manche gehen in die
kirche manche gehen nicht in die kirche
manche haben viele geschenke manchen
weniger geschenke manche essen eine ganz
manche essen fondue und manche singen
manche nicht und wir haben früher
tatsächlich weihnachten auch ein
bisschen traditioneller gefeiert als
mein opa noch lebte er wollte immer
unbedingt einen weihnachtsbaum haben und
weihnachtsliedersingen das haben wir
dann auch gemacht jetzt machen müssen
nicht mehr und laden zu weihnachten
menschen aus anderen ländern zu uns nach
hause ein
und ja so feierte die familie an dass
weihnachten ja nur schaffst du noch eine
frage für uns ja und zwar von vitali
fock in liebe kari wir erwarten sie in
russland vitali du willst uns nach
russland
das ist ja der perfekte anlass für ein
für uns da hinzufahren 4 1 hin
denn jeder dem barofsky janika war in
paris kein blut iba das ist das einzige
was ich auf russisch sagen kann wir
möchten sehr gerne nach russland kommen
wir möchten eigentlich überall hinkommen
und wir haben ja schon euch vorletzte
woche gesagt dass wir eine ein
web-formular aufgemacht haben also ein
google formular auf dem ihr euch
eintragen könnt um uns einzuladen
und wir meinen dass sie wirklich ernst
denn wir möchten nächstes jahr eine
weltreise machen wir sind tatsächlich
angefixt von unserer usa reise und das
war eine so schöne erfahrung dass wir
gesagt haben wir möchten nächstes jahr
um die welt reisen mit unserem projekt
und ihr könnt dabei sein nämlich wenn
ihr deutsch unterrichtet wenn ihr
deutschland egal was ihr macht ladet uns
ein und selbst wenn ihr am anderen ende
der welt sitzt in südkorea oder in der
mongolei oder in brasilien
wir möchten euch aufrufen uns einzuladen
in den link findet ihr hier unten in der
infobox der erste link den ihr findet
und wir werden die leute die vier leute
wie die fünf länder mit den meisten
einladung werden wir besuchen also
schreibt uns einfach
wir werden das auch noch mal ein
bisschen größer ankündigen aber ihr
könnt uns jetzt schon schreiben
tatsächlich ist von nicola milenkovic
herrje was für eine gitarre ist das hast
du eine band falls ich zu berlin um zu
machen wir eine okay ich eher spiel was
nicola das freut mich total
sobald du in berlin bist melde dich und
wir zusammen zumindest das und ich habe
jetzt gerade ein neues projekt
angefangen weil ich so kleine übung so
ließ
selber komponiert aber auch ständig nach
jemandem suchen die mir dabei helfen
würde
und dafür werden wir mit sicherheit ganz
viel spaß damit
johannes hat seinen eigenen gitarren
channel wenn ihr gitarre lernen möchte
vor allem bluesgitarre dann schaut mal
hier unten wir haben den link auch hier
unten rein gestellt das ganze heißt wer
bloß lab und janosch wird dort noch sehr
sehr viele videos zum improvisieren auf
der gitarre hoogland schloss ist die
nächste frage neu und heißt hallo - wenn
sie bitte erklären welche wer hier
unterschied zwischen falls und wenn ist
der unterschied zwischen falls und wenn
es ganz einfach pfalz ist nämlich eine
konditionelle findet man das eigentlich
das verbindungsglied zwischen versetzen
konjunktion konnte also der unterschied
ist falls ist konditionell ist es also
eine bedingung und wenn es temporal es
hat also mit der zeit zu tun
ich sagte immer zwei beispiele falls du
nach berlin kommt gehen wir zusammen
einen kaffee trinken
das heißt du bist noch nicht sicher ob
du überhaupt nach berlin kommt aber
falls du kommst gehen wir zusammen einen
kaffee trinken
der zweite satz ist wenn du nach berlin
kommt gehen wir zusammen kaffee trinken
das heißt du hast schon geplant nach
berlin zu kommen und die frage ist nur
wann du kommst
deshalb sage ich dir hey wenn du nach
berlin kommt gehen wir zusammen einen
kaffee trinken denn ich gehe davon aus
dass du irgendwann nach berlin kommt
vielleicht früher oder später das war
der unterschied von tadic teen english
and soldiers zuvor milliardär branson
willing to invite you pay also darin ob
ihnen in one day you guys wie sieht der
mittel ist
ende juni kommt aus dem libanon und wir
haben ihn schon einmal in wien getroffen
danke für deine nachricht also das ist
so wenn du uns einlädt kommen wir mit
zehn leuten und wir wohnen für vier
wochen in einem haus und du musst alles
bezahlen
nein das ist natürlich nicht so ihr
könnt das auch im formular eintragen
wir möchten die wir zahlen eigentlich
die reise selber wenn ihr eine
möglichkeit habt uns zu unterstützen
wenn ihr zum beispiel eine universität
habt oder eine schule die etwas bezahlen
kann freuen wir uns wenn ihr ein haus
habt oder eine wohnung oder ein zimmer
wo wir auch wohnen können dann freuen
uns auch wenn ich auch gerne sehen wir
das aber irgendwie anders
also vielleicht vom in den libanon
schick uns mal bitte deinen einladung in
unser formular denn dort sammeln wir
alles und dort können wir dann auch
sortieren
woher wir das ganz gut dass einmal
englisch und in der form die volkspartei
für technisch von libanon deine freiheit
so nah ist von israel
hallöchen karin und janos aus brasilien
ich habe eine frage für karry bist du
geschichte oder soziologie leben hinein
israel ich bin nichts lehrerin geworden
ich habe eure geschichte und soziologie
unter anderem studiert und weil ich gar
nicht wusste was ich machen wollte und
jetzt leite ich eine ngo das geht auch
mit dem studium kann man ja alles
mögliche machen aber lehrerin wollte ich
nicht werden auch wenn ich es mag mit
schülern zu arbeiten
ok und jetzt kommen die letzte frage
die tafel oh oh das ist ein freund jan
ist ein echter guitar fälle und es heißt
danke ich der mann für ihre videos und 4
janus sex ist nicht homogen zu dieser
liebeserklärung
ja es gibt leute die so leichter der
männer als sexy wie zb auf jeden fall
auch wenn das nicht ernst gemeint sein
kann
weißt du gar nicht vielleicht hab ich
das ja heimlich geschrieben unter einem
pseudonym ja leute das sind schon wieder
zu ende wir haben alle fragen
beantwortet und am ende möchten wir euch
einladen es gibt nämlich möglichkeiten
für euch dass ihr euch mit uns in berlin
treffen denn wir laden euch ein dass
papa schmidt wir laden euch ein nach
berlin und zwar haben wir am 9
dezember eine weihnachtsfeier die easy
german weihnachtsfeier das heißt wir
treffen uns mit unseren zuschauern in
unserem büro und es gibt essen aus aller
welt
ihr könnt auch essen mitbringen aus
euren ländern und wir werden zusammen
essen und feiern das ist unsere idee
german weihnachtsfeier am 9 dezember
guckt auf facebook da findet ihr alle
details wer geht denn das
guck mal wer ist danach hallo hallo
entschuldigen sie darf ich sie ganz kurz
etwas fragen hallo hallo dass man sie
denn von mir das ist mein papa und ihr
kennt ihn aus der super easy german
motorradfahren
wie fühlst du dich jetzt als
youtube-star ja ganz toll hätte ich
nicht gedacht dass ich meinem alter
nummer filmstar bekannt wer schöne sache
und carina macht das ja auch ganz toll
also ihr könnt uns mehr kommentare
schicken ihr könnt mir das video schauen
ich blende dass man hier unten ein
das video mit dem motorrad von meinem
papa jetzt noch eine letzte einladung
denn die weihnachtsfeier ist nur eine
gelegenheit uns zu treffen und mit uns
deutsch zu sprechen und das andere ist
unsere esi german winter school wir
haben im letzten jahr schon eine summer
school gemacht hatten trotzdem ich viel
spaß mit einer kleinen gruppe von euch
die nach berlin gekommen ist dann
zusammen ausflüge gemacht aktivitäten
gemacht schnitzeljagd treasure hunt
gemeinsam kochen und dabei haben wir
deutsch gelernt also immer wieder
übungen gemacht die aber einen echten
aktivitäten angeknüpft fahren das heißt
wir lernen die sprache in aktion sowie
auch in unseren videos und das möchten
wir jetzt im winter wiederholen
natürlich mit schönen winter wiederum
das winteraktion wir werden zusammen
schlittschuhlaufen
wir machen eine schnitzeljagd durch
berlin im winter wir werden zusammen wir
bewerben uns mit schnee wir fahren an
die ostsee zusammen
und wenn ihr lust habt damit zu machen
findet ihr alle informationen bei easy
dot org / hashtag summer school
auch wenn sie im winter ist den link
findet ihr auch hier unten also wenn ihr
mal mit uns für eine woche in berlin
deutsch lernen möchte und der fokus
liegt wirklich auf der konversation wir
wollen mit euch üben dann meldet euch
ihr müsst nicht perfekt als ihr müsst
noch nicht ein hohes level sein wir
haben letztes jahr angefangen leuten die
a2 niveau sind bis zu c 1 niveau und das
hat super zusammen funktioniert also
wenn ihr lust habt eure deutsch
konversation zu üben dann solltet ihr
unbedingt nach berlin kommen und an
unserer winter school teilnehmen das war
es von uns ja nur schaffst du noch ein
abschließendes einen abschließenden groß
an unsere zuschauer
liebe grüße von mir auch und wenn jemand
von euch bloß gedankenspiel plus soll
das spielt dann wird er hilft mir ich
brauche hilfe
nachhilfe ich brauche unterricht oder
jemanden der mir ein bisschen zeigt wie
es weitergeht schöne grüße aus münster
wir werden hier das gute wetter genießen
und auch eine episode drehen mehr davon
sind ihr nächste woche schaltet auf
jeden fall am sonntag ein denn dort gibt
es unsere neue episode aus göttingen die
wir gestern gedreht haben
dankeschön orange versucht jetzt